Speaker 1: Alex Jones is turning on Trump
and Trump supporters. And I have to tell
you this a broken clocks, you know the entire
thing. Alex Jones analysis of Trump's Tuesday
night rant at. Mar-A-Lago actually is quite
accurately assessing the reality of Trump
and his own supporters. I'll just play it for
you. Alex Jones is making a lot of sense here.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Oh, yeah.
Speaker 1: Okay. Other than this noise,
he's making a lot of sense. Thank you.
Speaker 2: Oh. That's not the sound I want
to hear, but this is one of my big irritants
with high level Trump supporters. They're in
their drink and it's a big carnival. They love
being near the president. They love the fancy,
beautiful architecture. Yeah. And they just it's
it's like a beauty pageant or something. Like,
it's like they've arrived. I've
seen it. I've been around it,
and there is just a delirium. And the same thing
happened. His rallies. Oh, we're invincible. Oh,
we can't be stopped. It was just drove me crazy.
But sometimes there's 2 minutes of applause.
And and whooping and hollering and you just
it's like they're having fun. This is not fun.
I've just been around the Trump people and
around Trump when there's people around and
everybody's like, Oh, hi, and I can't believe
they're there. And oh, it's it's like you're
in the cool kid club. And I've been saying
that. For six years, but he never did it.
Speaker 1: All right. So I have to tell you, Alex
Jones is completely correct. Yeah, there is a
delirium in the room at these events, like the one
at Mar a Lago on Tuesday, the vibe at Mar a Lago.
We were watching it for like an hour before
Trump spoke. We could see what was going on.
It was like you were there for something positive.
And I know some of them are trying to spin it into
the indictment is good because it means Trump is
going to win. It might help him in the primary.
I don't think it helps him with even a single new
vote in the general election if he makes it that
far. But there is again, we just talked about
cult like it's cult like, and Alex Jones knows
about cults. He's tried to build one. I mean, the
Infowars audience is not exactly clear thinking,
but he is completely correct that it. Why is
there a party atmosphere at Mar a Lago? He's
been accused of 34 felonies. There are more
allegations coming now. I know they just write
it off. They say this is all just bogus. But
there is a detached from reality. A delirium
really is is the best word for it that Alex Jones
accurately points out. And I, I almost think Trump
could get sentenced to prison and he would
be turning himself over to start his sentence
and they would have a party and cheer because
somehow some cult leader would tell them this is
actually a good thing. And I'll tell you why. It's
bizarre to see. Let's hope that it leads to their
own destruction electorally in 2024. We've got
a packed program today. Glad you're here. Quick
break and then it continues. The David Pakman
Show unlike much of what you get on cable news,
actually does depend on individuals who say, I am
going to sign up for a membership. We don't get
cable subscription fees like Fox News. We don't
have huge oil conglomerates advertising with us.
We actually depend on small dollar contributions
from people who sign up at join Packman dot com.
You can, of course sign up using the coupon code.
Indicted. We know what that means and you can also
sign up using the coupon code indicated if
you prefer either one works. And of course
we understand the meaning of each of these coupon
codes very, very well. All right. Let's hear from
some people in the audience. We take calls via
discord at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
It is an extraordinary situation this week,
historic in many different ways. And I do want
to hear from people in the audience. Let's start
today with Jackson from Sanford. Jackson from
Sanford. Welcome to the program. What's on your
mind today? Jaxon from Sanford, you're on. Once
you select your correct audio device, will be able
to hear you. And Jackson from Sanford is gone.